I took a little diversion on the way
back from filming last week's video it
is very cold and windy at this altitude
but tucked away in the Swiss Alps
there's a military Airfield with not one
but two public roads that go straight
across the runway and I've wanted to see
this for a long time this is my ring and
air base and not only do the fighter
jets here have to cope with civilian
traffic crossing their Runway but the
spectacle of military aircraft roaring
down the tarmac attracts tourists from
all over the world so I wanted to ask
how do they operate an air base where
the public aren't just turning up to
watch but they can also walk ride or
drive straight through I don't know how
many times I took off how many times I
landed but I'd say around 100 tagos
which equals 100 Landings but every
single one is very cool there at times
there can be a lot of tourists and
observers all around the Airfield
especially in summer they stay beyond
the bearish there are outside of the
fence but it's all Threat Level
dependent so at the moment we're at
peace there's no problem if we were to
find ourselves in the crisis would be
another story
okay
all right where am I allowed to stand
all right look them you're going to be
awesome Yep jets are going to come from
that side
gonna take off here okay you're safe
I mean you fly them so
when we're ready for takeoff the air
traffic controllers close to Bears they
themselves have a look if they see
anything suspicious and then whenever
the Bears get close there's guys from
the military police on both sides of the
Bears also there's the runway controller
who observes every takeoff and every
Landing he could step in as well so we
as Pilots we can't do much ourselves
there are a few other runways in the
world with roads across them but they're
all very small and very remote in sumbra
on the island of Shetland in the far
north of the UK there is a commercial
airport with a similar setup across one
of its two runways but that is very
remote it used to be that the only Road
in and out of Gibraltar went right
across a massive Airport runway one that
took full-size passenger Jets but there
is finally a new tunnel there now after
years of delays so cars and trucks no
longer go that way so this Runway here
in Switzerland would be just a little
side note if it wasn't for the tourist
industry that sprung up around it if
you're the sort of Aviation or military
nerd that wants to see fighter jets up
close and personal this is probably on
your list of places to visit and if you
didn't know about it before this video
it probably is now there's a very nice
restaurant just off the base one of the
hangers is open to the public
occasionally and there's a massive
military air show every October this
place is good PR for the Swiss Air Force
if ever there should be anyone between
the barriers when we're coming back to
land we would be ordered a go around so
we would abort our approach climb again
and do a second approach whenever the
issue has been resolved when we take off
it's basically the other way around we
taxi towards the runway and once we
report ready to the air traffic
controller they close the barriers and
they gave us our clearance to take off
once everything is settled it's not like
there are any statistics compared but
that Crossing is probably more safe than
most railroad crossings although to be
fair the rail industry is trying to get
rid of as many of those big chances to
Saint Aaron and necessary safety risks
no one's going to build a tunnel like
your soldier anywhere near
I
cannot explain how loud that was I've
got full ear Defender ear plugs in I
think it might have broken my microphone
wow we had one take to get that over and
thrust my lines